The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
Welcome to April fool's day.
But we'll be serious
about atomic physics.
I hope you enjoyed
your spring break.
At least I did.
It's just a little
bit change of pace.
So let me remind you what
we have been discussing.
We have been talking
about interactions
between neutral atoms.
And that can be trivial
and very profound.
Trivial because you've heard
about van der Waal's forces.
Polarization forces
between neutral atoms.
And if you describe
them phenomenologically,
you just have 1 over r to
the 6 or whatever power
of an interaction.
On the other hand, if
you take the position
that everything which happens
between neutral objects
has to be mediated, has to be
created by the photon field,
then it becomes a question of
the vacuum, the vacuum which
surrounds the two neutral atoms.
And I've tried in this
chapter to show you
both sides, to similar or
the same physics from two
different perspectives.
We talked mainly about the
van der Waal's interaction
between two neutral atoms.
I don't want one to-- we
pretty much finished it,
so I just give
you a bird's view.
I don't really repeat
a lot of things.
Because today we want to
talk about the forces which
happen between neutral atoms in
metal plates and then two metal
plates, which is
the Casimir force.
But just to remind
you that we showed
that the forces
between neutral objects
are actually created by
quantum fluctuations.
Classical objects would not
create fluctuating dipole
moments, would
therefore not create--
would not give rise to any
force between neutral atoms.
And I showed you that
there are two aspects where
quantum physics comes in,
namely through the fluctuations
or the zero point motion of
the atoms as oscillators.
And we even had a
circuit model for that.
But then I also said
that, well, assume
that you have two
neutral atoms and you
have the vacuum
fluctuations of the field.
This vacuum
fluctuation is driving
coordinated synchronized dipole
moments between the two atoms,
and then the two atoms
can attract each other.
So we have seen the dual role
which quantum physics plays
here in terms of
quantum fluctuations
of the atomic
oscillators and quantum
fluctuation of the
electromagnetic field, which
is another harmonic oscillator.
And at least when I use
very simple pictures,
it seemed that the 1 over
r to the six potential,
the standard van der Waal's
potential at short range,
comes from the vacuum-- from the
fluctuations of the oscillator.
I didn't do the derivation,
but the simplest derivation
for the long range Casimir
Polder retarded potential,
1 over r to the 7, focused
on the fluctuations
of the electromagnetic field.
So these were some
preliminaries.
Then I thought I want to show
you the power of diagrams
by showing to you that there are
two different kinds of diagrams
dominant at short range
and at long range.
And with that we realize
diagrammatically that, because
of the nature of virtual photons
which are exchanged by the two
neutral atoms, there is
a change in power law.
The power-- the inverse power
of the distance between the two
neutral atoms is one
higher at long range.
And long range meant-- that also
became clear diagrammatically.
Long range means the distance
is longer than the wavelengths
of the resonant
radiation for the atom.
Any questions about that?
So the goal for the first hour
today is to go from two atoms
to many, many atoms, which
then form a metal plate,
and make the transition from
forces between neutral atoms
to forces between two
metal plates, which
is the famous Casimir force.
And I want you to sort of
hold the thought about what
is really the
quantum aspect here?
Is it the vacuum?
Is it the zero
point fluctuations
of the electromagnetic field?
Or are the atoms the
zero point fluctuations
of the atomic oscillators
responsible for those forces?
So we'll come back to it after
we have discussed the Casimir
interaction between
two neutral plates.
So maybe one highlight for you
today is that maybe in an hour
you have should at least
have an expert opinion
whether zero point fluctuations
of the electromagnetic field
are real or just a convenient
way to describe some physics.
But let's get there.
So the way how I want to
make the transition from two
neutral atoms to
two metal plates
is by reminding you that the
potential was proportional
at long range to 1 over R to the
6, at short range at 1 over R
to the 6.
And if you had the model that
the long range interaction
comes, because the
vacuum fluctuations drive
dipole moments in the
two atoms, then we
know that the potential
is proportional
to the polarizability
of atom one times
the polarizability of atom two.
So let's now extend
that to the interaction
between an atom and a wall.
Well since I don't
know-- at least not
yet-- how to describe the wall.
I take the position
that, well, we
have an atom come
close to a wall,
but now I extend the wall
to a sphere of radius z.
And it's not obvious that if an
atom interacts with the wall,
if the wall were flat,
it is of course this part
of the wall which
is most important.
So we should actually get
a quantitative or semi
quantitative result out of that.
But now I can use a nice
result from electrostatics,
which I also discuss in 8421,
in the [? MO1 ?] course, namely
when we have a conducting
sphere of radius c.
Do you know what the
polarizability of a sphere is?
You must have also
had this problem
in classical electrodynamics.
You apply an electric field.
You calculate with the boundary
condition of the sphere
some spherical
harmonic function.
You calculate what
the dipole moment is,
and you find the
proportionality constant.
AUDIENCE: It's like z
squared or [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The one thing I want is that
it's proportional to z cube.
It's the volume of the sphere.
And the reason why I discuss
that in atomic physics
is when we talk about
the dipole moment
at the polarizability
of the hydrogen atom,
we find that the polarizability
of the hydrogen atom
is the pole radius cube.
So it seems that when it
comes to electric fields
and polarizability, an atom, a
hydrogen atom behaves exactly
like a conducting sphere,
and the size of the sphere
is now the size of the atom.
But that means now that the
long range potential will now
be proportional the
polarizability of the atom.
And we lose three
powers in the power law,
because we have
three powers of z
in the polarizability
of the sphere.
OK, if that worked
so well once, we
can now use that at
least as a bridge
to discuss what happens when
we have two metal walls.
Well, we can now say
we have two spheres,
and the polarizability
of each sphere
is proportional to z cubed.
Well when we have
two walls, we want
to use the potential per area.
So what we had is we
had 1 over R to the 7.
We lose three powers of R
or z, because of one sphere.
Another three powers of the
other sphere, so it's 1 over z.
But when we normalize by area,
it becomes 1 over z squared.
And now we find that the
potential is 1 over c cubed.
And at least with it
I have-- I wouldn't
say derived, but motivated
for you the famous Casimir
potential, which
is 1 over c cubed.
And I want to give you an
exact derivation of the Casimir
potential in the
next few minutes.
But before I do that-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Why did you
choose the spheres to be
the same size as the
distance between them.
That seems kind of--
PROFESSOR: It's
all just a trick.
[LAUGHTER]
You know what would happen
is-- let me just go back here.
If I would choose
this sphere smaller,
I would not have given the
atom the whole exposure.
I have to make it
at least larger
than c to make sure that
the curvature of the sphere
doesn't dominate and
what the atom sees
is it sees there is a wall.
But then you can see when I
make this sphere larger than c,
then I delocalize
the dipole moment.
And the bigger sphere
has a big polarizability,
but the atom which is
so close to the sphere
doesn't care about it.
So you would say
the right choice
is just when you think either
picture gets corrupted.
But that's often what it is.
So if you think about
it, it's the only choice.
Both other choices would
lead to an unphysical result,
and you would
immediately realize why.
In one case it's the curvature,
and the other case you're not
really sampling the
dipole of the sphere
because you want to
do a dipole field,
and if you have a dipole of size
z, the field with the dipole
starts to be an approximation
if you go distance z away.
Other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain where
the first term [INAUDIBLE]
z to the [INAUDIBLE] come from?
PROFESSOR: We had it.
Last class we had the
result that the Casimir--
that the van der Waal's--
the retarded van der
Waal's potential is
1 over R to the 7.
But with the physical
picture in mind
that the van der Waal's
potential at long range, which
is 1 over R to the 7 comes
because a vacuum fluctuation
drive to dipoles, and the two
dipoles attract each other.
When each dipole is alpha
1 times a vacuum field,
the other one is alpha
2 times a vacuum field.
But now for this sphere,
alpha is z cubed.
So therefore three
powers in the denominator
cancel, and I get z to the 4.
So you can say the
alpha 2, I absorbed--
I used the kind of result
that alpha 2 is z cubed,
and then the alpha 2
cancelled with three powers
of the distance in
the denominator.
Other questions?
I have a question for you now.
If you have two metal plates,
what about short range and long
range?
We expect something
under the rock.
If we assume a metal
plate, what is the vessel--
we had the distinction between
long range and short range,
which came from the
resonant radiation
from the resonant
excitation of the atom.
And when we are closer
than the wave lengths,
we're in short range,
if you're further
than the wavelengths of
the resonant transition,
we're in long range.
Between an atom and a
plate, well, we still
have the resonance of the atom.
But what happens when
we have two plates?
There's clearly no
resonance, so therefore there
is only one power
law, 1 over z cubed.
But I want you to sort of
think about it for a moment
whether this is now--
whether everything
is long range or
everything is short range.
In other words, you say
effective resonant radiation,
you say effective wavelengths
of the plate lambda
equals 0 or lambda
equals infinity.
Any opinion?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ability, so it
must be infinite [INAUDIBLE].
Take the two metal
plates, the vacuum energy
between those
plates, and compare
it to vacuum energy at
the same volume free space
and subtract the [INAUDIBLE]
energy difference.
And high frequency components
cancel out, so you have the--
PROFESSOR: OK, we'll actually
do exactly what you suggest,
to compare vacuum energies,
in the next few minutes.
It's not quite
obvious, but I want
to tell you now we
have made-- by assuming
the metallic boundary
condition, by assuming
that we have idealized
metal plates which fulfill
the boundary condition
that the electric field is
0 at the surface.
The parallel component of the
[INAUDIBLE] at the surface.
We've made an assumption here,
and the assumption is actually
that the resonant
wavelengths goes to 0,
and resonance frequency
goes to infinity.
And the power law we obtain
is actually the long distance
power law so to speak,
and for two metal plates,
there is no short distance.
I'm not sure if I can give
you a simple explanation
because the boundary condition
is so idealized that you don't
recognize, you don't smell
any atomic resonance anymore.
But maybe the one
thing I would say
is that you say the boundary
condition, metallic boundary
condition for infinitely
high frequency.
And sometimes that
would also mean
that the plasma frequency of
the metal is pushed to infinity.
We come back to that
in the next chapter.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Excellent question.
I will go for you now through--
its mainly classical e and m.
This is why I use
pre-written slides.
We sum up over all modes
with a boundary condition,
with a metallic
boundary condition.
If you have in general a
dielectric or semiconductor
which is not an ideal metal, has
different boundary conditions,
the Casimir force will change.
And this is actually a pretty
outstanding difficult problem
where people have
really chewed on hard.
I think Lifschitz has some
famous solution on it.
What is the Casimir force for
an arbitrary dielectric constant
of the surface material?
But absolutely yes.
If you don't have a
metallic boundary condition,
your Casimir force changes.
I think this is sort of
an interesting point,
and it may trigger
immediately discussions
what does it really mean.
But let me go now through
school the derivation where
we have metallic
boundary condition,
and this actually leads to
a quantitative derivation
of the Casimir force.
Quantitative in the
way that we get--
we're not just
getting the power law.
We get the prefector.
We everything 100%
of this derivation.
Collin?
AUDIENCE: So what is the
mechanism for the Casimir force
changing?
Because if think of it in the
picture of two metal plates,
the lower density and modes
inside and then do outside.
Even with the arbitrary boundary
condition, I [INAUDIBLE].
But what is the
physical mechanism
for changing the form?
PROFESSOR: To the
best of my knowledge,
it is the density of modes.
But it's very subtle.
I suggest, since not
everybody is probably
familiar with the
way how I will count
all the modes in the metal
plate, let me just do that,
and then we should-- and
I hope then it's obvious,
or we should then discuss
the boundary conditions being
modified.
And you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yes, but maybe we
can discuss it after this.
PROFESSOR: So the
idea is the following,
if the Casimir force
is only due to zero
point fluctuations of
electromagnetic field--
let me say up front this
is a valid assumption.
I get a valid result.
But I tell you in
half an hour that you
can take another
perspective and say
this is just a
holistic description.
There are other derivations
of the Casimir force
which do not use the concept
of zero point energy at all.
So in other words,
I'm presenting
you one presentation of
the problem, one solution
of the problem, but there's a
whole different formulation.
But here I assume-- mean
I can easily modulate.
OK, well here we have
two metal plates.
We want to understand if
there is potential energy
and interaction between
the two metal plates.
And let's just calculate what is
the total energy of the system.
And if I have two
metal plates, which
are two mathematical
boundary conditions,
all I have to calculate
is the ground state
of the electromagnetic
field in between.
And that means I have to
find all of the modes,
and each mode contribute
h bar omega over 2.
So this is our agenda now.
We say the metal plates
are not real objects.
They're mathematical
boundary conditions.
Looks like a good assumption.
And now based on those
boundary conditions
we calculate the zero
point energy of the world,
at least of the
electromagnetic world.
And then we ask if the plates
are a little bit closer,
tool has the total zero
point energy changed?
And when it has
changed that means
there is a force between
the atoms because
of potential changes as
a function of distance.
So this is the agenda
I went to execute now.
Any questions about
what we want to do?
As you know when you
write out modes in e and m
and you want to do it exactly
the many, many indices.
But this is a result
of which could actually
come straight out of Jackson.
For your convenience,
this is also
discussed-- a wonderful
discussion by Serge Haroche.
In some these summer school
notes from the '70s or '80s.
I've posted those on the web.
So if there is a mathematical
detail you want to look up,
this is posted on the web.
So anyway, we have two metal
plates with a distance l.
And we have metallic
boundary conditions.
That means that when we
calculate the modes, we get TE
modes and TM modes.
TE modes means there is no
longitudinal electric field.
TM modes mean there is no
longitudinal magnetic field.
And the frequency of each mode
is discrete in the z direction.
In the z direction we
have standing waves,
which are labelled with
an intentional value of m,
whereas parallel to the plate
the modes can have an arbitrary
transverse wave vector k.
And when we look at the
dispersion relation,
the frequency of those
modes is in quadrature.
You can see the
component k squared c
squared of the
transverse propagation
plus the component
of the standing wave.
So for each m, for
each integer value,
we have a TE and TM mode, with
the exception of m equals 0.
For m equals 0 we
don't have a TE mode.
We only have a TM mode.
So that's just fresh
out of Jackson.
But it's very
important now-- and I
want to spend a little
bit more time with it
so it's just a purely
classic result.
What is the density of states?
Well, let's assume
we have a given m.
So we have a standing
wave perpendicular
to the capacitor
plates, and therefore
now the density of modes only
comes-- the density of modes
only comes from the transverse.
Let me just get my toolbar back.
So it is from this k squared.
And you know that
the number of modes
is proportional to
the volume in k space.
And the important part is that
I can write this as dk squared.
But k squared is
d omega squared.
And this gives me omega d omega.
So for each n value, for each
discrete mode perpendicular
to the plates, we
have now a density
of modes which goes
as omega d omega.
Before I show you the
mathematical expression,
let me just sort of plot
that, what that means.
The density of modes was--
the number of modes was omega
d omega.
That means the density of modes
was proportional with omega.
That means for m equals 0
we started omega equals 0,
and we get a straight line.
For m equals 1-- m
equals 1 shown in green,
and m equals 2 shown in purple.
The frequency omega--
we have omega squared
is sick the quadrature sum
k squared and m squared.
So therefore if you
want to ask what
is the density for modes for
m equals 1 or me equals 2,
you have to start at the lowest
frequency for m equals 1,
at the lowest frequency
for m equals 2.
But then as we just derived,
the density of modes
is proportional to omega.
So what you we to
do in the end, we
want to sum those modes all up.
And what we will
observe is that here we
have a line with slope 1.
Here we have to sum
two lines with slope 1.
three lines with slope 1.
So progressively, the slope
gets higher and higher.
But the slope, which increases
linearly with the coordinate
axis.
If it were continuously,
would just be a parabola.
So in other words, if
I would [INAUDIBLE]
the density of states which
comes from the exact mode
spectrum, if I
would [INAUDIBLE],
it would be parabola.
And parabolic density of
state, the number of modes
is omega squared d omega.
This is three dimensional space.
So in other words, what
we observe is what exactly
the effect of the
boundary condition is.
Instead of getting this
smooth parabola omega squared,
we have sort of
broken up the parabola
into piecewise linear pieces.
And the fact that we have
a boundary condition,
that we plates in free space,
and not just the space,
is actually the difference
between the two.
So it is the difference
between the two, which
leads to the fact that a
boundary condition modifies
the vacuum energy.
Questions?
OK with that the
rest is mathematics,
but I want to show you
the steps because it
is ingenious mathematics.
It makes a few approximations.
It creates a few infinities
and gets rid of it.
It's actually rather wild,
but amazing that, in the end,
we have a simple exact result.
OK so the most important thing
is we have a density of states.
And the density of states for
one m is proportional to omega,
but now we have
to multiply-- when
we want to know what is the
density of state in a given
omega, we have to
multiply with the integer
number of discrete modes which
are available at this omega.
So this is because there is
only one m equals 0 node.
We have a one here.
And then for m equals 1 and
higher, we have two [INAUDIBLE]
between TE and TM.
So this is just
counting the modes.
And this is now a
mathematical trick
that, instead of
counting the modes--
it's an integer-- we can sum
up heavy side step functions
and sum over all m.
This is just an
[? exact v, ?] right?
But this is something which
helps us in the next step
to do an integral.
So now so far we haven't
made any approximation.
We've just reminded
ourselves what
is the exact result
of classical e and m.
OK, but now we want to
calculate the zero point.
So now it's getting
interesting, because we
take the classical result, and
take it into quantum physics.
The first step is very innocent.
We say each mode contributes
h bar omega over 2.
And then we integrate with
the density of states.
And the next line is
also an exact result,
just using the density of
modes from the previous page.
But of course, now we
are asking for trouble.
We are integrating with
omega squared d omega,
and there is uv catastrophe.
Now I can say I can put
on my mathematical head
and say let's add a
convergent term, something
which exponentially decreases
with omega, which is just
cutting off the
high frequency part.
And I hope that in the end--
and this will come out too--
that I get a result which is
independent of the cutoff.
So by choosing this cut of
parameter lambda to zero,
I have-- if this is
zero, I have no cut off.
So maybe I can introduce a
cut off, and then at the end
let lambda go to got to zero.
And if this gives me
a physical result,
I've sort of mathematically
tricked around.
But I also like the physical
justification for that.
I mean you know that a
metal plate tennis has
not metallic boundary conditions
at infinitely high frequency.
If you go deep to the
x rays and gamma rays,
it becomes transparent.
So therefore, we would argue
that, once we go to very, very
high frequencies,
the modes do not
feel that there is a
boundary condition,
and therefore we may be allowed
to do some physical cut off.
OK so we do this
cut off by-- so now
we have to find the
zero point energy.
The zero point energy
has a sum over m.
And I call each
integral I sub n.
And this integral
is the omega square
from the density of
states, but now multiplied
with a convergence term.
Whether it's
mathematical or physical.
And by introducing
this cut off, I
can now exactly
solve the integral.
The omega squared can be
taken out of the integral
by taking the second derivative.
And this is just an
exponential function
which can be integrated.
And therefore we have a
mathematically exact result.
So we are now able
to do the integral
because we have
avoided the divergence.
OK.
Now we come back and say we are
really interested if the cutoff
is pushed to higher
and higher frequency.
And this means lambda equals 0.
So therefore, we want
to take this expression
and expand it around
lambda equals 0.
Well, you could say that's
physically very well motivated.
But if I take this
function, which
is lambda e to the lambda
over x times e to the x,
and expand it, I get
divergence is 1 over x squared.
So you would say how
can you expand it.
Let's see what happens.
Let's just do it.
Let's say we are interested
around lambda or x equals 0.
We have some
divergencies now, but we
have to find a way
to deal with it.
So we get rid of some
of the divergencies
in the following way.
By saying, well, if you simply
calculate the zero point
energy between those
two capacitor plates,
and then when,
let's say, if there
is-- if the plates come closer
and there is less zero point
energy, we would see the
plates attract each other.
But what happens is the
plates are not moving,
and there is no
world behind them.
The world is sort of as it is.
And that means we
have to sort of now
look more carefully at the zero
point energy of our capacitor
plates where l is small.
And the rest of the world.
So we are now
representing the world
as a big capacitor of size l 0.
And then our plate
is just moving
within that, because we are
not assuming that then the two
capacitor plates
attract each other
and move towards each other
that the size of the universe
is changing.
So we want to move a boundary
condition within the universe.
So therefore, the correct
expression for the zero point
energy is not the zero
point energy of capacitor l.
It's the zero point
energy of a capacitor size
l plus of a capacitor
l0 naught minus l.
And so we take the
result and simply add
the expressions for
l and l0 minus l.
And what is now a nice is that
the first highly divergent term
with 1 over lambda
to the 4-- reminder
that we want to let
lambda go to zero.
It becomes independent of l.
So we would say, well,
if there is an infinity,
it doesn't change with l.
It doesn't provide a potential.
It's just one of those
infinities which is constant,
which is not
affecting the physics.
Also here, this is
independent of l.
And then the next term gives us
the famous Casimir potential,
1 over l cubed, and it
is independent of lambda.
So we have the result which
was independent of the cut
off we introduced earlier.
So therefore, we have
derived, with a little bit
of hand waving to
navigate about infinities,
that the potential between two
metal plates is 1 over l cubed.
a squared was the area, the
size of the capacitor plates.
And this is the exact prefector.
Or if you want to
figure out what
is the pressure off the vacuum.
Pressure is, of course,
force per unit area.
So you take the derivative
of the potential that's
the force, that's the
force per unit area,
and this is now the
vacuum pressure.
Sort of funny now you
can put in the unit.
It's 10 to the minus 5
millibar at a distance
of one micrometer.
So anyway this is, I think,
the classic deviation
of the Casimir potential
by, I would say,
exactly summing
up the zero point
energy within a certain
boundary condition.
Good.
Maybe to address
Collin's question.
What would happen if the
metal plates were maybe
semiconductors or had a
different dielectrical
constant.
The mode spectrum would change.
AUDIENCE: Like if you had
mixed boundary conditions.
You don't have these
nicely spaced--
PROFESSOR: I don't
know how to calculate.
That's a hard problem,
and a lot of people
have really worked
very, very hard on it.
It seems for idealized boundary
condition you can do it easily,
but it has been
clearly a challenge
to mathematical physics.
And I'm not even sure if it has
been solved in all generality
or only in special
examples to extend that
to every type of surfaces.
But we can, for instance, assume
if you have a conductor, which
is not-- conductor which has
not infinite conductance,
0 resistivity, then
the electric field
can penetrate a little
bit into the conductor.
And if the electric
field penetrates into it,
it changes the
frequency of the mode.
So it's clear that the boundary
conditions have an effect here.
But let's now have
some discussion.
We had focused before on
the force between two atoms.
And if we use a microscopic
model for the metal plates,
it should be, it must be
possible to obtain the Casimir
potential by just summing up
all the forces between atoms.
Because ultimately if
you have no metal plates,
you don't have any force.
Where s-- in the
last few minutes,
we focused on the derivation
which was simply summing up
the zero point energies.
And there are two
papers which I've
posted on the wiki which
argue that both results are
equivalent.
So I would really
recommend to you--
he expresses it much
better than I can.
Read the introduction
and the conclusion
from Bob Jaffe's paper.
He clearly says in
the introduction
that there are a lot of books
and references by famous people
who have said the
Casimir force is
the manifestation of
the zero point energy.
The fact that people have
observed the Casimir force
means that h bar
omega over 2 is real.
Those authors take
the opposite approach.
They say this is just heuristic.
It's convenient.
You can get the correct result.
But there is an
equivalent derivation
which gives exactly the same
result, which focuses only
on pair wise interactions
between atoms,
and it does not include any--
it doesn't make any reference
to the zero point energy of
the electromagnetic field.
So therefore, one, I would
agree with those authors
that the conclusion
is there is absolutely
no observational evidence
for the zero point energy,
that the zero point
energy is sort of not just
convenient counting, but
that it is real energy.
And the Casimir
force, of course, also
it has often been quoted
as a counter example
that this is a
direct observation,
is not-- should not
be regarded as such.
Now people at MIT
probably know Bob Jaffe.
He's a high energy physicist.
And why is he interested
in atomic physics?
Why is he interested
in the Casimir force?
Well, the question of
zero point energies
is very, very important in
these days for dark energy.
I mean, you know that 80% of
the energy of the universe
is dark energy.
Then there's dark matter, and
then there is baryonic matter.
But this dark energy
is really mysterious.
And one candidate
for dark energy
is the dark energy simply comes
from the zero point energy.
So therefore, people
are now really
interested is the
dark energy real.
And if it is real, does it
have a gravitational effect?
Does it change the
metric of space?
And can it accelerate the
expansion of the universe?
Of course, you have a problem
if you calculate the zero point
energy, you don't
introduce a cut off.
You have a spectacular
uv divergence.
You can maybe now
concatenate the divergence
by saying, OK, eventually if
the wavelengths become shorter
and shorter and shorter,
there is a cut off.
And if you have no
idea at all, you
would introduce a cut off
at the Planck lengths,
because beyond
the Planck lengths
all physical
descriptions break down.
But if you cut it off
at the Planck lengths,
you find that the zero
point energy of all modes
is larger than the observed
dark energy in the universe
for acceleration of
the cosmic expansion
by 124 orders of magnitude.
And if you think you want
to introduce a cut off which
is maybe the classical
electron radius.
The classical electron
radius is the radius
of a charged sphere for which
the electrostatic energy would
just be the rest
energy of the electron.
Well, then you're off by
43 orders of magnitude.
So some people have called
those discrepancies,
which are completely
unresolved as of now,
the biggest failure ever
of theoretical physics.
So anyway, that's why there is
renewed interest in the Casimir
force.
And at least in
electromagnetics,
we have a very,
very simple model.
And we have experiments which
measure the Casimir force,
but, as I've said, it cannot
be regarded as a direct
observation of the
zero point energy.
OK, let me now
come to a question
we started discussing earlier,
namely if we-- here we
have atoms.
Here we have a metalized
boundary condition.
So maybe let's just talk
for one minute about it.
What kind of assumptions
do we make about atoms
when we replace them by a
metallic boundary condition?
From the whole derivation
of the Casimir force
it's not obvious that there
are no atomic properties which
have entered the calculation
of the Casimir potential.
What Bob Jaffe argues in
this paper-- and again,
it's wonderful reading.
I really recommend Just if you
want to enjoy some physics,
open up the document and read
the first and the last page.
The Casimir force from an
idealized boundary condition
is completely independent
of atomic properties.
So therefore, it must be
a limit where-- well, we
talked about the
resonant wavelengths,
but we can also talk about
the fine structure constant,
because the fine structure
constant in a hydrogenic model
provides what that resident
transitions in hydrogen are.
So you can argue if
something is completely
independent of
atomic properties,
somehow by sweeping things
under the rug we must have set
alpha to either
zero or infinite.
Because if it is
set to any value,
it would correspond to some
version of the hydrogen
atom which has a
resonant radiation.
So the question is,
is alpha set to zero
or is alpha set to infinity when
you derive the Casimir force?
And I think this is
now easy to discuss,
because the fine
structure constant alpha
is e squared over h bar c.
If you set alpha
to zero, you do it
by setting the charge
of the atoms to zero,
and then you have no
interaction at all.
So therefore, if you
want to have the Casimir
force in a limit which
is independent of atomic
properties, the alpha equals
zero limit gives no force.
So therefore, the
equivalence this picture,
summing up over the electrons
and obtaining the Casimir force
for the metallic
boundary condition,
this equivalence happens
when you do this derivation
and set the fine structure
constant to infinity.
How big is the fine
structure constant?
1 over 137.
In some expansions of
alpha and alpha squared,
it's actually a
smaller parameter.
And now I'm telling you when
you have two metal plates
and measure the
Casimir force, this
corresponds to the
infinite alpha limit.
So this is now
getting complicated
and I can refer here only
to Bob Jaffe's paper.
But he shows that when you
go to distances of 0.5 micron
that people have measured
the Casimir force.
You are already the alpha
equals infinity limit.
If you are-- I wish I
could read my handwriting.
I think that's minus 5.
If alpha is larger
than 10 to the minus 5.
So therefor, alpha equals 1
over 137 is for that purpose
already very, very well
in the large alpha limit.
But I just hate
this result here.
This is rather complicated.
Bob Jaffe says that to get the
Casimir potential by summing up
over atoms is actually
a quite challenging
mathematical exercise.
Questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If these calculations
of summing over atoms
has been [INAUDIBLE], then
what is it-- we can just
talk about the plates being
dielectric from that atom
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: There are solutions
for dielectric plates.
And sometimes when
people do experiments,
the best surfaces you can
get is a silicon surface.
Because they want you to do
qualitative measurements,
they're discussing corrections
due to the dielectric constant.
I know the problem
has been worked out
for dielectric surfaces.
I assume not by doing the
transition from summing up atom
by atom, but by rather
looking at the boundary
condition for
electromagnetic fields
in the presence of a dielectric.
But I don't know more
details about that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: This question
may not make sense
because I haven't
thought [INAUDIBLE].
But again, when we
consider two plates,
if you have room for two
atoms, we get the two 1 over R
to the 6, 1 over
R to the 7 cases.
Once of which is the
retarded Casimir potential,
but for two plates-- again, we
conclude that it was more like
the short range--
PROFESSOR: Well, long range.
We are always retarded.
AUDIENCE: OK, but then
I'm a bit confused.
Because then if you say
alpha goes to infinity,
don't you have an
h bar or c to zero?
Oh wait.
That makes sense.
PROFESSOR: Alpha
infinity is-- we
know that this is the
vastness of the electron.
The [? Whitbeck ?] constant is
alpha squared times smaller.
And the [? Whitbeck ?]
constant-- well,
a quarter of the
[? Whitbeck ?] constant
is alignment alpha radiation.
So anyway, the
[? Whitbeck ?] constant
is a scale factor in the
transition frequencies
of the hydrogen atom.
And so therefore,
it is consistent
that, if you make alpha
large, we actually
get-- we push the frequency
of the atomic transition
to very, very high frequencies.
And that would mean the resonant
wavelengths goes to zero.
And therefore any finite
distance between the capacitor
plate is, in the long
range, is longer than
the wavelengths
of the transition.
AUDIENCE: I think
equivalently you
could say if the speed
of light is really slow,
you always will
have [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sure.
You can do the
transition in many ways
by tuning the speed of
light, or tuning the charge,
but it all has the
same implication.
Other questions?
Lindsay?
AUDIENCE: Is there any
other observable reason
why we should
constantly be thinking
about Casimir forces
and dark energy?
Like experimenting [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: As far as I know,
this question about dark energy
and whether it is
related or not to zero
point energy of the
field is completely open.
I think if you had an idea
how to do a decisive-- if any
of you had an idea how to make
a decisive experiment measuring
whether zero point
energies are real or not,
that would have a big impact.
As far as I know,
it's completely open.
Nobody has really good idea.
So some people feel,
mathematically, the zero point
energy has the right, correct
physically characteristics.
Zero point energy could
explain the extra term
in Einstein's field
equation, which is often
called the cosmological
constant term.
But the quantity, it's so
many orders of magnitude
off that people don't even
know if that is correct or not.
One could also say, well,
maybe zero point energies
do not give rise at all to
any gravitation potential.
And therefore maybe if
energy doesn't give rise
to gravitational potential,
maybe the energy is not real.
And what we find, what is
responsible for the expansion
of the universe is gravity--
so Einstein's-- what's the
constant called again?
I just mentioned it.
AUDIENCE: Cosmological.
PROFESSOR: Cosmological.
So that is just the
cosmological constant,
but the cosmological constant
reflects something else
in the universe and
is not related at all
to zero point energy.
To the best of my knowledge,
these are the possibilities.
OK, so let's go back to atoms.
Our next big chapter 12
is on resonant scattering.
Just that you see the
structure of the course.
I wanted to introduce sort of
some mysteries and subtleties
of electromagnetic interactions
to you by using diagrams,
by using an exact
formulation of QED.
And then I gave you
one example where
we could use those
diagrams, and these
were van der Waal's forces.
So we got a little bit side
tracked with the vacuum,
with van der Waal's
and Casimir forces,
but now we want to go
back to the diagrams.
And there is one aspect
of the diagrams which
is sort of fascinating,
and this is where we really
need a treatment which goes
beyond perturbation theory.
And this is when we
have resonant radiation.
When resonant light
interacts with atoms.
Because, as I'm
going to show you,
we have then in any
perturbative expression
zero in the energy denominator,
and we would have divergence.
So I want to show
you now, partially
also for the beauty of
the physical theory,
how can we deal-- how can
we fix those divergencies?
How can we fix
those infinities we
encounter in
perturbation theory?
The answer will be we get
rid of these infinities
by summing up an infinite
number of diagrams.
So I'm going to show
you now-- it actually
sounds so much more
harder than it is.
How, with rather modest
mathematical effort,
we can perform an infinite
sum over diagrams.
And I want to show you
what those diagram are.
And the result of that is that
the divergencies disappear,
and we have a valid
description of what
happens when atoms encounter
resonant radiation.
So I'm following here,
almost religiously,
the atom photon
interaction book.
So this in production is
a summary of those pages.
So when we discussed
diagrams, we
wanted to figure out what is
the amplitude for a system
to go from an initial
to a final state.
And those were the
matrix elements
of the t matrix, the
transition matrix.
And if we do it in
second order-- well,
remember the structure
is in second order.
We sort of emit a
photon, virtual or real.
We have another photon.
This gives us second order.
And in between the
system propagates
with its eigen energy.
So this was the structure
of the diagrams we had.
And this term here,
let's expand it
in one wave functions of
the unperturbed Hamiltonian.
And then we obtain this
following structure.
So this is just rewriting
in a very suggestive way
what we had discussed before.
And the case I focus on
now is the interaction
of atoms with resonant
light, because this
is when we have divergencies.
If we have state a, state b.
We have a laser and
we scatter light.
If the frequency is
approximately resonant,
then those perturbative
results have a divergency.
So for resonant light
scattering, the typical matrix
element we are interested in,
we start and end of course
in the ground state.
We scatter photon.
We go up to an excited state
and go back to the ground state.
But we started initially with
a photon of wave vector k
and polarization epsilon.
And this may be different
for the scattered light.
The interaction happens by
the interaction operator,
which, for the purpose
of this discussion,
can either be the A dot p
term or the d dot E term.
We've discussed about
the special role
of the a squared term.
We discussed it earlier.
I don't want to include it
in the discussion right now.
And then you would
say-- just want
to make sure they
do not confuse.
In second order
perturbation theory,
you always have an
energy denominator.
But as I also explained to
you, the energy denominator
comes from the free propagator.
You had a dot
propagate and a dot--
and what is the time evolution
of this free propagation when
you integrate it with time?
This gave rise to the
energy denominator.
Just a side remark.
So you should be
very familiar that we
have an energy denominator.
But now this energy
denominator--
the initial energy is
the initial atomic state
plus the photon.
And then if you want
to sum over all states,
I can just put in
here the operator H0.
But you may immediately think
about it, the only state which
really matters is the state b.
And what matters is only when
we go through intermediate state
b, then H0 is Eb, and
then we have a divergence
because the denominator is 0.
So let's see how we can fix it.
But let me first give you
the perturbative result,
which you have seen
many, many times.
It is the product of
two matrix elements.
We have an intermediate state.
The excited state
without photon.
We started with a photon,
and we end up with a photon.
And here we have our
dipole or A dot p term.
And our energy
denominator diverges
when the frequency of the
photon approaches the resonance
frequency.
Well, how can we fix it?
You know that in
many cases you're
just adding an
imaginary part to it,
which reflects that, due to
the coupling with the vacuum
of the electromagnetic field,
the excited state is broadened.
And it gives its energy
an imaginary part.
This of course is
very phenomenological,
but at least technically
it avoids the divergence.
Now what I want to show
you, in the next 15 minutes
and we continue on
Wednesday, is how
I can get this result of
a very rigorous approach.
I want to use the
diagrammatic approach.
I want to sum an infinite
number of diagrams.
And will tell you what are the
approximations to get this.
For instance, as you know, when
you have an imaginary part,
when you have just an
imaginary part of the energy,
the physics of it is
exponential decay.
Well I hope, not today
but on Wednesday,
you realize what assumptions
lead to exponential decay,
and that, in principle, non
exponential decay is rather
the standard than the exception.
But the effects are small.
But I want to show you.
So in some sense
I want to give--
we have to go through
a half an hour of work
to derive this result.
So you'd say, what's about it?
You just get the
phenomenological result.
Well, we have put it
on a rigorous basis.
And number two is we do
understand what assumptions
really go into this
phenomenological result.
So the way how we will
actually obtain this result
is that in-- the second order
diagram is that you start
in state a, you go in state
b, and you're back in state a,
and you exchange photons.
So the way how we-- the physical
picture we want to use now
is after the photon is
absorbed right here,
the system is not propagating
with the Hamiltonian H0.
It will propagate with
the Hamiltonian H.
If we do that, then we
avoid the divergence.
We get a result which can be
applied toward-- the formalism
can be applied to
many situations.
And in one limiting
case, we obtain that.
So the physics behind
it is the following.
The divergence which we
encounter in resonant physics
is only a divergence because
we assume the atom in state b
is naked.
It's an excited state
of an isolated atom.
But in reality, the
state b interacts
by virtual photon
emission, interacts
with all the modes
of the vacuum.
And once we throw that in
by saying that between two--
between absorbing and
emitting a photon,
the state b propagates not
with a free Hamiltonian,
but with the total Hamiltonian,
we avoid the divergence.
But this is no longer
a perturbative result.
And let me illustrate
that to you.
If you take the energy
denominator, omega minus
and omega 0, and we add
the imaginary part to it,
I can Taylor expand it, assuming
the imaginary part is small.
Well, that's sort of
a trivial expansion,
but now you should
know that gamma,
the rate of
spontaneous emission,
the simplest
expression is obtained
in [INAUDIBLE] is called
null in the second order
in the interaction Hamiltonian.
Spontaneous emission
is proportional
to the atomic dipole
matrix element squared.
So it's second order
in the Hamiltonian.
But that means that
this harmless addition
of an imaginary part means
that if you look at the Taylor
expansion, that we are
using now infinite orders.
Infinite orders
in this expansion.
So the phenomenological
addition of [INAUDIBLE] gamma
to the excited level b is
actually highly nontrivial,
because it's
corresponds technically
or physically to a non
perturbative result which
involves infinite order in the
interaction matrix element.
Question about it?
So this is more
setting up the agenda.
I wanted to remind you of
the perturbative result.
I want to sort of show
you how we can fix it.
I want to show
you what it means.
But with that motivation
I want to now back
to our diagrammatic approach,
our formal solution,
our exact formal solution of the
time evolution of a [INAUDIBLE]
system, and show you
one how I can implement
this agenda in particular by not
allowing the atom to propagate
with a naked
Hamiltonian H0, but sort
of staying dressed with
photons and propagating
with the Hamiltonian H.
Questions about that?
OK, so the derivation
is now focusing
on two chapters in API.
I need one result which I hope
you remember from about a week
and a half or two weeks ago.
We formulated the time evolution
of the system using the time
propagation operator u.
And we found an
exact expression.
I'm dropping all of the
arguments here, t and t prime.
You can look them up
either in the book
or in the previous
lecture notes.
We found that the propagator in
the interaction representation
is the unperturbed operator u0.
Now I need, actually, the terms.
It was a time integral
over some time
t1, which involved u0, v, and u.
And I introduced it to
you as you could plug that
into whatever is the
equivalent of Schrodinger's
equation for the time
evolution operator,
and you really find this
is a solution for u.
But well, it's not
really a solution,
because it's a solution of
u expressed in terms of u.
But then I showed you that it
allows an iterative approach,
and this is why we did it.
If you have a
first order result,
the zero order result is u0.
When you plug the zero
order result in here,
you get the first
order correction.
When you put the first
order result here,
you get the second
order correction.
So you get a recursive formula
which solves the problem.
And this is now
our starting point.
This is an exact
formulation of QED.
And this is now
our starting point
to address the problem
of divergencies.
We want to describe what
many of you do in the lab,
namely have resonant laser
light interact with atoms.
And I want to show you how
can you describe it with QED
with the formalism
we've introduced.
OK, now for this chapter we want
to have one big simplification.
Things aren't only
getting complicated.
They're getting simpler.
If you have a time integral
which is a convolution,
and you can often simplify it
by Fourier transforming it,
because the Fourier
transform of a convolution
is simply the product of
the two Fourier transforms.
There is one glitch.
So one subtlety I want
to feed in a moment.
But let's just
assume for a moment,
we go from time
before the Fourier
transform to
frequency or energy.
So G of E is the
Fourier transform
of-- after filling a
few corrections of u.
That would mean,
if that were true,
the equation above
would now be an equation
where the integral,
V sort of constant,
instead of a
convolution of U0 and U,
we get simply the product of
the two Fourier transforms.
That's much, much simpler.
It's an algebraic
equation instead
of an integral equation.
And remember, when we
get into nth order,
we get n integrals with
some time ordering.
We were able to do it,
but it's mathematically
more complicated.
The problem is that this
is not a convolution.
It would be a convolution if
the time limits were infinite.
So what we can do instead
is we can define G of E.
Not the Fourier
transform of U. If we
say it is the Fourier transform
of k, which uses a step
function, then if you insert
now k in the formula above,
you see that because
of this step function
we can now take the integral
limits from minus infinity
to plus infinity.
So therefore, when I say G,
G is called the resolvent.
It's really the
mathematical quantity
we have to work on now.
And I wanted to tell
you very simply hey,
it's just a Fourier transform
of the time evolution operator.
Not quite.
It's the Fourier transform
of a time evolution operator
with a theta function, just
to make sure that formally we
can extend the upper and lower
integration limits to infinity.
Or this is also a
name-- what I'm really
kind of discussing are
Laplace transformations.
But I want to convey
to you the physics.
It would take many weeks to do
the mathematical accurately,
but you can get the idea
and really profound feeling
for how QED works
and what we are
doing with not so much
mathematical rigor.
So with that grain
of salt we have
Fourier transformed equation.
We have the Fourier transform
of the time evolution operator.
But if you look at it
mathematically more exact,
it's a Laplace transform, and
we are little bit navigating
in the complex place.
The Fourier transform does
not exist for real values.
We always have to add
a small imaginary part
to make things converge.
But you've seen that in
many other places, I assume.
OK, so the quantity
which allows us
to describe resonant interaction
in a very straightforward way
is called the resolvent.
I can simply define
the resolvent.
All I gave you was
some motivation.
But if I had
wanted, I could just
say the resolvent is defined
by this operator equation.
z is the complex number.
H is the Hamiltonian
including interaction
between atoms in
electromagnetic field.
And actually if you would
take that-- if you take this
and plug it into the equation
above-- so if you plug this
into the equation, you find this
expression solves the equation.
So I just want to
say you can forget
about all the subtleties with
Laplace transform and such.
You can just say let me define
some interesting object.
But it is connected to
what I said earlier,
because this solves
this equation.
And also I like to sort of show
you the mathematical structure.
If you write the time
evolution operator as e
to the minus the Hamiltonian,
and now you Fourier
transform it.
If you Fourier transform
it, you multiply it
with e to the I omega
t, and you integrate--
let me integrate
from 0 to infinity.
There are some issues
with 0 or infinities.
But if you simply solve
this integral with time,
you have sort of an exponent
e to the i omega minus h.
So if you Fourier
transform it, what
you obtain is nothing else
than the energy minus h.
And this looks very different.
This looks very, very
similar to the definition
of the resolvent.
The only mathematical thing
I'm not fully discussing here
is z real, or has it a
small imaginary part?
The small imaginary
part-- actually,
you have to add a small
imaginary part here
to make sure the Fourier
transform exists.
But you should clearly see
how things are connected.
So OK, I'm focusing
now on the resolvent.
It is equivalent to the
time evolution operator.
It is a sort of Fourier
transform of it.
And we want to
formally write down
a diagrammatic solution
for the resolvent.
And with that I think
I should stop now.
We start on Wednesday?
Any questions to that point?
OK, then see you on Wednesday.